hey guys so this past week I spent in
Austin Texas through this amazing event
called South by Southwest now if you've
never been to South by Southwest or
Austin Texas for that matter it's this
huge crazy event they put on every year
for film interactive and music
you wanted to share with you what myself
myself list consists of started off
mostly going to panels they read all now
it's a practice which just Google head
because she's pretty much the person
that created video blogging actually
that was the only one that I went to and
then I hang out with a bunch of my
friends yeah you you code a lot he was
cat rittvik djc mr. Australia himself
and hey it's Rachel miss Texas herself
hi Justine hi I keep on into what you
mr. often went to a bunch of really fun
parties trying to get as a nation party
event except we need 17 rest and I think
really up to we got work done alright
got beat by Ashton Kutcher and an arcade
racing game what airborne
action cheetahs so yeah we masters close
but I saw this really creepy baby tied
to the back of a motorcycle
creepy creepy tried to put myself into a
suitcase on 6th Street
in
you guys taking that
of course last but not least I asked you
guys in one of my other iJustine vlogs
what I should do well is in Austin so I
had you guys give me three fun things
that I should do and now here they are
Sena and Austin
under way cuddle
your suggestion
our YouTube video bloggers oh yeah we're
going for a ride swift soul for robots
alright we are not the Capitol building
Here I am here on Commerce Street here
we've got we are gonna go and watch the
bats there's a bad we respects
good news we found the plates ride the
ball I'm extremely excited and
yeah Dean are you nervous okay I'm a
little nervous I get up knit out I'm
ready
I think I might not go is that
profession that's it to see all the
videos that I shot was in South by
Southwest check out my youtube comm such
other I've seen channel yes well I kind
of couldn't prove anymore footage into
this one little video without making all
of you people with a do do you want to
punish me in the face the country